niger president mohammad isafu votes
not to stay in power but to elect a
successor
he chose to step aside at the end of his
second term
at the time some west african leaders
tweaked their country's constitution
to remain in office the significance of
this day
is not lost on the 69 year old president
today is a special day for us it is also
and most of all a special day for nijaya
which will experience for the first time
in its history a democratic changeover
and i hope that this change will be the
first step towards other changes in
order to solidify our democratic process
i hope this first changeover will enable
niger to solidify its reputation as a
democratic country
in africa and in the world and this is
the man he designated as successor
former minister of interior and foreign
affairs
bazoo muhammad is challenged by 29 other
candidates
among them two former heads of state and
a former prime minister
hussein adamu says he's voted in every
election since independence
and is here again to choose a leader for
niger
every time i do this as a duty to my
country but also expecting our leaders
will fix our problems
but for samira abubakar it's the thrill
of voting for the first time
i can tell you it's exciting it's like
no other i like casting my ballot
the elections were held amid safety
concerns after an uptick in violence
killed more than 50 people this month
among them members of nigeria's armed
forces
many voters list security and poverty as
their main concerns
now attacks by armed groups near the
border with nigeria mali and burkina
faso have killed hundreds of soldiers
and civilians in recent years
the local economy has also been hit hard
by covet 19
a fall in the prices of its main export
uranium
as well as a long-term closure of the
nigerian border
that many essential goods are imported
across
officials held the elections as a
success for the most part
there are a few places where the
elections could not be held but in many
others we were able to organize voting
despite security threats
results of the elections are expected to
be announced within five days
and ratified by the constitutional court
in two weeks
a winner will need fifty percent of the
vote plus one
to avoid a runoff otherwise the top two
candidates
will head to a second round in february
next year
ahmed al jazeera near me